[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a melbourne pues
el nuevo primer ministro australiano
anthony albanese se inaugura con una
discusión sobre la seguridad en la
región el líder viajó a japón para el
encuentro del diálogo de seguridad
cuadril lateral también conocido como 4
una alianza entre india japón eeuu y los
australianos china advirtió que mirara
qué postura asume al bani si y si se
diferencia o no de la estrategia anti
china que tuvo su antecesor
scott morrison conectemos entonces con
nuestro corresponsal
camilo montoya camilo bienvenido de
nuevo y empecemos primero hablando de
cuáles son los retos que esperan en
australia con el nuevo primer ministro
antónio albanis y especialmente en
materia ambiental
durante su campaña y a lo largo de su
carrera política el nuevo primer
ministro de anthony albanese ha sido
crítico de la falta de acción contra el
cambio climático teniendo en cuenta que
australia es uno de los mayores emisores
de carbono per cápita del mundo y uno de
los principales exportadores de carbón y
gas por eso uno de los mayores retos que
enfrenta albanisa es pasar de la
oposición a la acción el partido
laborista ha prometido que reducirá las
emisiones de carbono y australia en un
43% para el año 2030 y que diseñará
políticas públicas para convertir al
país en una superpotencia de energía
renovable
albanesi deberá trabajar para reducir el
alto costo de vida en australia causado
en gran parte por el primer aumento de
las tasas de interés desde 2010 la clase
trabajadora espera mucho del nuevo
primer ministro que deberá definir el
aumento del salario mínimo además tendrá
que diseñar planes de prevención para
las temporadas de incendios y de
inundaciones que son fenómenos naturales
comunes alrededor de australia y por
supuesto deberá hacer un ajuste a sus
relaciones internacionales
bueno camilo y como ya lo decíamos al
bani si se encontrara con joe biden en
japón en medio de una gira en asia con
la que la casa blanca intenta reforzar
lazos con los países del indo pacífico
donde china tiene mucha influencia en
este panorama cuál será la posición de
australia y concretamente cuál es la
postura de anthony albanese
el partido laborista pasó nueve años sin
el poder federal y muchas cosas han
pasado con china desde 2013 sobre todo
por el reciente pacto de seguridad
firmado entre ese país y las islas
salomón que australia que me podría
llevar a beijing a establecer una
presencia militar permanente a 1600
kilómetros de suelo australiano por eso
la reunión con eeuu y japón es clave
para garantizar la seguridad en la
región indo pacífico antes de viajar al
encuentro de este grupo de países
conocido como quad albanis y dijo que
esperaba que la relación con china
siguiera siendo difícil pero que el
gobierno perseguiría el interés nacional
de australia sin politizar la seguridad
nacional fortalecer la relación con sus
principales aliados en la prioridad en
relaciones exteriores para el nuevo
gobierno y sin duda eeuu juega un papel
importante en el tema de seguridad pero
también en el ambiental australia quiere
que exista un compromiso mayor para
combatir el cambio climático y de hecho
una de las metas de albany y si es que
el país se hace de una conferencia
internacional sobre este tema se espera
entonces que estos temas sean tratados
entre el nuevo primer ministro de
australia anthony y si el presidente de
eeuu joe biden
gracias y ya veremos qué pasa en esta
reunión nosotros seguimos con más aquí
en directo américa